bonsoir
affrontements dont entre migrants et
policiers polonais la situation devient
on peut le dire incontrôlable sur place
effectivement stéphanie le terrain
contre la baie et à très bien a choisi
encore une fois à des images transmises
par les postes de gardes frontières le
gouvernement polonais avait anticipé
cette situation avait prévu cette
situation puisque en l'espace d'un jour
le nombre de migrants à la frontière a
pratiquement doublé en est passé de 2000
à 4000 migrants selon les autorités
locales sur tout le long de cette
frontière avec la biélorussie
le gouvernement polonais a donc renforcé
sa présence militaire et ça a
complètement dégénéré comme on a pu voir
sur les images retransmises à part le
ministère de l'intérieur le ministère de
la défense et les ministères de
l'intérieur polonais l'afflux de
migrants devient incontrôlable et ce qui
s'est passé c'est qu au checkpoint de
bruguières du côté des logos et bien
certains migrants ont commencé à jeter
des pierres en direction des forces
polonaises un policier a été grièvement
blessé dans les heurts un policier qui
était agrément blessé au crâne et à
partir de ce moment là les forces
polonaises ont répondu avec des tirs de
gaz lacrymogènes et des jets d'eau des
jets d'eau vous imaginez par des canons
à eau vous imaginez par ces températures
qui sont assez insupportable à vivre à
pour pour ces migrants qui se masse de
plus en plus à cette frontière polonaise
et qui tentent de traverser tant bien
que mal la frontière pour se rendre en
allemagne il y avait également des
individus qui se sont dirigés vers cette
frontière munis de buch voilà est-ce
qu'on a pu entendre en tout cas ait pu
voir sur ces images puisque comme je
vous le disais c'est une version des
faits avancée par le ministère de la
défense polonaise sur twitter mais de
notre côté pour nous les journalistes il
est toujours impossible de se rendre sur
ces zones a dit d'état d'urgence puisque
on en a fait les frais hier avec notre
arrestation les journalistes ici ne ne
peuvent pas travailler de la frontière
polonaise ne peuvent pas faire un état
des lieux de ce qui se passe en tout cas
du côté polonais
ce qui est ce qui sait ce qui se passe
également c'est que 183 communes sont
pour l'instant en état d'urgence est
fermé à ses journalistes à une première
depuis
1989 qui devrait se passer dans le futur
et bien selon les sources policières et
selon ce qu'on a pu comprendre hier
alors de notre arrestation est bien
c'est que des zones spécifiques pour les
médias vont être mises en place à partir
du mois de décembre à mois de décembre
particulier pour le gouvernement
polonais puisque vous le savez c'est à
partir de ce mois qu'un mur va être
érigé qui va commencer en tout cas à
être construit un tout du long de la
frontière avec la biélorussie un mur qui
devrait s'étendre sur 180 km et qui
devrait coûter 350 3,1 millions d'euros
une mesure qui est significative de la
tension palpable avec elle à habile
aussi en tout cas les tensions ne
comptent pas s apaiser un puisque de
plus en plus de migrants arrivent à 7,7
frontière avec la pologne dans l'espoir
de traverser le pays est d'arriver
jusqu'en allemagne pour rappel également
le ministère de l'intérieur a envoyé des
messages à tous les portables étrangers
qui se trouvent aux abords de cette
frontière avec des directives toujours
aussi claire ne tentez pas de traverser
la pologne pour aller en allemagne
épargner votre vie et pas renier votre
santé en clair rentrée rester ou rentrez
chez vous voilà la situation en tout cas
de ce qu'on a pu entendre et voir
puisque je vous le rappelle nous sommes
à bialystok à une cinquantaine de
kilomètres de la frontière avec la
biélorussie pour nous impossible
d'atteindre ces zones dites d'état
d'urgence merci beaucoup david kelly
phare en direct de pologne avec des
images signées jordi demory